サッブパパッスアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日の話に入ります まああの心を変える変換する時期になりますからね
今今日ちょっと買い物に行きましたけど
大騒ぎでもうベスト軒になってますね
方が 1ヶ月とかベストお経で私の欲しいものがなかったんですね
全部クリスマスの品物ばっかりで
まあそれでまた神道に戻らなくちゃいけないしね
この家に座ったら大変だと思います
で 今日のテーマは妄想というテーマなんですね
これは特別に講演する必要はないことなんですけど
お釈迦様がおっしゃっている教えの基本的なところというのもありますね
で 妄想やめてどうなるのかっていうことが
例えばね お釈迦様の言葉は全部妄想がなくなった時の言葉なんですね
だから誰にもかなわない
否定できない しっかりした真理を語っているでしょうね
というわけでね 妄想がなくなった方がとてもいいことだと思います
で まずは妄想ってどういうものかとね
あの 今日テーマに入る前に一応考えた方がいいと思いますね
妄想の定義はいらないが
意味を考えた方がいいと思いますね
結論に達しない思考の流れですね
妄想っていうのは とにかく考える
あんまりなんで考えるのかっていう目的もない
結論ないんですね だからものすごく
で 思考がループになっちゃうんですね
輪になっちゃうんですね
だからずっと同じことを考えて考えて考えて
で 自分でも止まることはできないんですね
自分の意思に反してやっているような感じになっちゃうんですね
この心の中で妄想っていうのは
まあもう考えることは似ていますからね
しかし 妄想にも時間がかかるんです
問題は 妄想しているとものすごい時間がかかってしまうんですね
だから他のことをやらながら勝手に妄想したっていいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
そうじゃないんです 妄想っていうのは大事な
全く無駄なことでしょうし
もう管理不可能で脳が回転していることですね
だから脳が暴走していて
それに時間かかっちゃうんだからね
それは大変損なんですね
ですから 人の人生の大半は無駄になります
そこでまあ これは私は書いてないんだけど
例えば 1時間ぐらいチェックしてみると
何やってるのかと  50
分 55分ぐらい妄想なんですね 1
時間の仕事にしたっても
まあ1時間本読むって言ったら
もしかすると30分は本を読んでないんで 1
時間はかかっている その間で関係ない要らん妄想が入ってるんですね
それで人生全体的に考えてください
80歳生きてるんだと
80歳で 60 年間ももう妄想ばっかりで何にも生産性ただ妄想していて
だから 20年しか生きてないんですよ
だから考えてください
だから我々は 80 年間も生きていて
すごいことをやったと思ってるでしょうね
もし妄想しなかったらどんなもんですかね
で 具体的で役に立つ結論がある
思考は妄想ではありません
それで思考妄想と区別しなくちゃいけないんですね
具体的で結論がある それは別に役に立ちますよ
例えば数学を学んだり
科学を研究したり 実験したり
まあいろいろ企画を作ったり
プランを作ったり いろんなことをやっているでしょうね
そういうのはある程度で具体的でね
それで生きているんだから
料理はよりおいしくするためにどうすればいいかとかね
まあ考えたりすることは
一応人間の役に立っているんですね
その場合は大体結論があるんですね
ずーっと悩む必要はないんですよ
かぼちゃ料理作りたいんだけど
まあ困ったなとか それで 1 年間悩む
もうかぼちゃ料理を作りたければ
もうもうさっさと終わっちゃえば
料理法わからなくても
本棚にある本を一冊引っ張り出しちゃって
開けてみて あ これこれぐらいですねと
もう終わりですよ もう料理の仕方か忘れちゃってもいいんです
もう台所の横に本を開けておいて
見ながら見ながらやっちゃえば
もう時間かかってないんです
今ね  Windows でもね
喋ったら色々料理の仕方とか教えてくれる
あのなんとかあるんだけど
私やりません もう毒食わせるかもだから
私の発音をどう理解するかわかりません
だから怖くてやってないんですけど
で 一つだけパソコンに何かネットで何か調べてくださいと言ったら
もう別なことを調べて出してくれたんですね
まあいいや 一回だけで終わりましたけど
いたってな この そういう日常生活でかぼちゃ料理を作りたければ
わからない人は困っちゃったなと思うんだけど
すぐ結論が出てくる だからそういうことは我々は思考だとしましょう
思考するのもわかってないからなんだよ
本当は だから誰かにね
まあ子供たちに出質問出しますよと言ったら
子供たちはもう考えて考えて答えなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんです
なぜならば 一発で答えはわかる
わかっているならば さっと答えちゃうでしょ
その場合は思考はいらないんですね
だからわかっているならば
思考さえもいらないんです
我々はいろんなことをわかってないんだから思考する
それでどんどんわかるようになっていく
しかし 妄想ってなんですか？と
5 分思考すると 20 分の妄想するんだから
それ相当な無駄だと思いますね
はい 次のポイントはこの妄想しているか思考しているか
どちらかわからないこと
それ発見しましょう これはなかなか簡単じゃないんですね
これ妄想 これは思考とね
難しいんです 私は思考だと思って妄想する場合もある
妄想だと思って思考することはこれはないんです
妄想 妄想だと勘違いして思考しているんだと
それはないんです それはもう優れた知識人も哲学者みたいな
そういう方々は妄想しているつもりですけど
思考しているんですね
これはもうすごい一握りの人間なんですよ
すごい知識人で 抜群の知恵の知識のある人々は
まあふざけて何か妄想しているように見えるんだけど
それは何かと調べたら大事な思考なんですね
でも本人にとっては妄想なんですね
だから もう思考妄想するつもりで思考する人々っていうのは数少ない超エリート
超知識人たちだけなんです
私たちは何するのかというと
もう思考すると思って妄想しているんですね
考えてるんだよとか考えてないんです
妄想しているんです で
考えてるんだったら もうさっと答えが出てくるんです
それだけで妄想は発見すること難しいんです
理性のある常識的な人間には努力すればできます
これ努力しないと 仏典に経典がありますけどね
思考の区別する方法とかはね
あんまり一般の方々にそれできるかどうかというとわからないんですね
すごく気をつけて精密に自分の脳を見なくちゃいかんですね
ですから これは思考です
これは妄想ですという区別は
結構理性のある人にできる
この具体 常識的な人間という
あの言葉をよく覚えておいてください
私たちは本当に常識的ですかね
本当に常識的だったら
まあ妄想と思考の区別はできるんです
だから まず常識的な人間になった方がいいんですよ
いろんな夢を持ったり
あれやこれやではなくて
朝何時に何するのか 何時にご飯食べるのか
何を食べるのか 仕事はどんな風にやるのかとかね
常識の世界 これはものすごいシンプル的にシンプルライフなんです
そういう風に生きてみると
こうやって今日はどうしよう
それはなくなっちゃうんですね
具体的と淡々と行動して
それに合わせて必要な思考だけする
そういう人には無駄な思考と役に立つ思考の区別はできます
だから無駄な思考 妄想で役に立つ思考は思考ですからね
そこでもう一つ 私はなんで難しいとか苦悩というと
妄想すると常識が壊れちゃって
精神的に病気になるんです
そこで現代知識では精神病やとレッテルを貼ってくれなくても
相当病気な人々がいるんですよ
世の中で 仏教はお釈迦様の立場から見れば
もうみんな病気ですよと
精神的に肉体は病気でない人々は結構いるんだよと
しかし 精神的な病気でない人はいませんと
だから病気な人にね 精神的な病気な人に
自分の思考を明確に区別することって
ちょっとありえない話なんですね
はい しかし ポイントを書きます
私たちは自分の思考はこのようにチェックするんです
1 この考えは役に立ちますか？という頭の中でグーッと何か思考が流れると
これ役に立ちますか？といういくらぐらい儲かりますか？と考えてください
この思考ではと これ 1番目
2番目 結論がある思考ですか？と
この思考でどこで終わるのかと
例えばお正月休みどうしましょうか？ということを考える
考えて あれもいい これもいい
あれとか悩んだりするかもしれませんだけど
決して結論がない思考ではないんですね
お正月休みだったら何かしなくちゃあかんだからね
そこで計画が 10種類くらい出てきて
いろいろ気に入らなくて
気に入らなくて 結局何もなくてゼロになる可能性もあります
ただ 家で寝るぞとテレビ見ながらとか
ということにもなるかもしれませんね
だから結論がある しかし
お正月ではね 世界一超極端につまらない番組しかないんだから
テレビでね で 自殺したくなるんですね
あれ番組流しちゃうと
で ああいう番組を見ていながら
なんかこんなつまらない
やっぱりどこかに行った方がよかったのにと
あれも妄想なんですね
1ヶ月前からはお正月休みどうしようかと考えたところは考えたんですね
それで結論はあるのに立てなかっただけ
ということは 思考は弱すぎ
データがなさすぎ 経験は足らなかった
そういういろいろ理由で結論はできなかった
子供にもあるでしょう
問題だっても頑張って解答を出そうとするんだけど
答えが間違っている場合あるでしょうに
そんな感じで我々も思考しても結論が出なかったということはあり得る
が それは思考で それでお正月何もしないことに決めて
もうテレビ番組を見ていると
超面白くなっちゃって
やっぱりどこかに行った方がいいんでよかったんではないかと考えちゃうとね
こんな家の中でテレビばっかり見ていたってもとか思っちゃうと
それ自体は妄想なんです
なぜかというと 結論ない
今更何考えるのかということでしょうに
今更何を悩むのかということになっちゃうんです
だから役にも立たない
これ  2番目の項目はそれで
3番目 日常生活に邪魔ですかと
私たちは朝起きて寝るまでいろんな日常生活を行わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それに邪魔だったら 例えば 10時にお風呂に入った方がスケジュール的にはぴったしと
寝る時間もあって 朝早く起きる時間もあってとかね
朝早く起きなくちゃいけない
だったら 10時ぐらいでお風呂に入って
11時定時で寝ちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと OK
でしょう 計画は これで 10時にお風呂に入ることが12時になると
私は毎日毎回ですけどね
で 12時半になるまでもっと時間があると思ってるんで 12
時半になったら一応悪い身体的なことで体がカッパスになるのは12時過ぎてから夜
まあそれはいいんだけど
それで10時にお風呂に入る予定でいたのに
お風呂に入る時は11時半か12時になったならば
あなたこの時間で何やったのかと
いえ いろいろ考え 考えていただいているでしょ
その時間で妄想したんですね
だから日常生活に大きなダメージが受けたんです
だから出かける時間が遅くなったのは何なのかといえば
いろんなあれもあって
これもあって これもそういう何かやることがあって遅くなったならば
それはわかります  もうちょっと何とか何とかとか
怠けたり妄想したりすると
もう日常生活にかなり邪魔になっています
4番目の項目 感情をかき回しますかと
あるいは沈みますかと
なんかわからないんだけど
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ いろいろ感情が
もうかき回されている
だったらそれは妄想です
怒りがあったのに怒りが消えてしまったならば
それは思考です すごい欲があったのに
欲がなくなったならば
それは思考です だから怒り
嫉妬 落ち込み 憎しみ 悩み
あれやこれやとか あらゆる感情がなかなか消えなくて
ずっともう現れて現れて現れて現れて
もうどんどん強くなっていくならば
確実に妄想しているんです
だから妄想そのものをわからない人は
自分の感情を見てください
怠けも感情の一つなんですね
なんか怠けがどんどん強くなっていって
後回しにするならば その時間で妄想しているんですね
自分では怠けだと気にしないかもしれません
もうちょっと後でやります
なんで後でやるのと 今私は忙しい
自分で聞いてみてください
そこで今忙しくて別な仕事を後回しにする場合は気持ちいいはずなんです
今手が空いてないんだからね
次にやりますと 暗い気持ちじゃないんです
仕事を見て まあ後でやりますということは妄想中です
だからその瞬間で なんで私は後でやりたくなっているのかと聞いてほしいんです
そうすると感情が怠けが入ってるんですね
怠けが勝ってるんです
怠けが勝ったということは
妄想したっていうことなんです
それだけやと思いますけど
項目はね この 4つをチェックしてください
そうすると妄想の発見できます
以上チェックすれば 妄想は少なくなります
そうすると妄想が少なくなって
ものすごい有効に生きることができます
だから 一番最初に言ったことを覚えてください
80歳の人が 80歳でいろんなことをやって
こういう成功があって
こういう人間になって
私はもうすごい有名人になってまでなっているんだぞとか
ほら 見てみなさいと言っている人がいるとしましょう
でもその人  80年間生きてないんですね
おそらく 60年間妄想中でした
いわゆる何も役に立つことをしなかった時間
もしその 60年間も 思考になったならば
我々にイメージできませんよ
どれほど人間が進むのかっていうことを
もう例えば今戦争あるでしょ？ ISIS IS
とかいろんなところで 100%妄想の結果でしょ
西洋も同じで アメリカも同じで
もうごちゃごちゃあれやこれやとか
もうだから戦争ならさっさとやって終わりにしなさいと言いたいんだけど
それができない だって結論ないんです
妄想だから ずっとそれで人類不幸になっているだけで
思考でやるならば ISIS
の問題をどうしましょうかと
思考なら結論必ずあります
私の個人的に考えると
私ならそんなのは解決できるでしょうと
解決できる問題はあり得る
現れませんよと でも 世の中の人間にはそれが何かと見えてこないんですね
この学生時代で  NHK でなんかの番組でもいろいろ話し合っていて
このクジラ食うことについてって
ちょっとそれで外国の学生さんたくさんいたんだけどね
みんなもう大反対 あれやこれやとかね
もう直ちにやめるべきだと
日本人がやぶ 日本人の文化ですよ
あれやこれやとか言っていて
もうもう折りがないんですね
私は黙っていてね 私の答えは
あのね クジラ食わなかったら
日本人が上に飢えるならば仕方がないでしょうと
言ったら 反応はあんた言うことわかりませんと
頭が悪すぎなんです 私は大量のことを 1行で言ったんです
クジラの肉でも食べなかったら
日本人が栄養失調になって飢えるならば
クジラでも殺して食べなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だから私への答えは アホな人々に解説すると
日本人が文化的に歴史からクジラ殺していたかもしれません
当時ではそんなに食べ物あった
豊かなということでもなかったし
しかし今はもう社会が開発しちゃい
食べるものはもう何トンもね
100 万トンぐらい毎日捨てているし
今の社会問題は食べるものはないではなくて
どうやって食べることを抑えるのかっていうことでしょうね
その上 海に行ってクジラ殺すってやめなさい
そんなこと その意味なんです
世間にいろいろ言われるわ
バカ扱いされるわ だからってクジラ肉持ってきたんだからって大したことはないわ
現代若者は食べないわ
だから私はどちらのヨーロッパ人の方も持つ
日本人の方も持つ 正しいならば
このステップだよと言ったことはわかりませんと
あなたの話は だからわかるわけないでしょうと言って黙っていたんです
だから私がその上出したのは
今思い出したんだからですけど
あの どんな問題にも問題あるとは解決方法もあるっていうことなんです
例えば うちの誰かさんが末期がんで
もう体も動かない もう寝たきりになっちゃって
もうほぼ危篤状態やと
危篤状態やと問題でしょ
解決策はあります 妄想しないならば
妄想する人は何かハンドパワーでもがん治りますか？とか聞くかも
そうじゃないんで放っておきなさい
気にするな 人は誰だって死ぬ
それだけそうすると落ち着いて
もうあと何日でしょうかね
どうかね 思いつつも もう悲しいし悲しいだけど
さっさとそばを離れないで
その人のそばにいて やっぱり一人ぼっちで最後の息を止めたら
これは申し訳ないとかね
明るくやりますよ その時は
だから妄想さえなければ
どんな問題にも答えがあるんです
だからまあ世界世界で世界一悪人になっているのは
私がすぐ答え出すんだからなんです
それはもうまずいとわかっているんだけど
やっぱり言っちゃいますよ
いつでも答えを だから妄想して 1週間話し合いたいんですね
議論したいんですね 会議をやって
なんだこれはと だから大変損なんですね
妄想というのは みんなやっているのに
なぜ妄想は悪いって？まあ一応答えちゃったんだからね
大量の時間が浪費する
我々はもっと時間に対してケチであった方がいいんです
もう極端に節約思考で
時間に対して なぜならば時間はどうでもいいんだけど
自分の寿命 限りなく生きるわけないでしょ
秒単位で年取っていくんです
秒単位で生きる時間が短く
短く 短くなっていくんです
それ妄想して何もしないでいる
だからこれ浪費なんですね
だからまあ 西洋でも言葉があるでしょう
何でしたっけかな 日本人も欲張りだから日本語にされてますけどね
タイムイズマネーとかね
リザルトイース geld とかドイツ語でもありますからね
で 金は財産なりとかね
だから金じゃなくて 時間はね
時は金なりと で なんでそれ実行しないんですかね
だから金なりっていうのはすごい品のない単語で
だからそこは仏教的にちょっと気持ち悪いんだから置いといて
時間ものすごく節約して
有効的に充実するために
人生をより良い人生にするために使っちゃえばいいでしょうに
より楽に より楽しく 苦がより低く
悩みがゼロで 自分にも周りにも役に立つようにと生きるようにと
なんでこの自分の寿命という回数券を大事に使わないんですかね
寿命っていうのは回数券の束なんですよ
これは 1 日1枚  1 日 1 枚使わなくちゃあかんです
後で使うために置いておくことはできません
毎日 1 枚が行くんです
それで大量の束を燃やす
あるいは使えないように汚す
だから妄想したっても1日いきますから
それで回数券使ってないで汚しちゃって無効なんですね
だから結果はない 回数券だったら得られるものありますよ
人生で充実感があって幸福に生きられるという
今日 1 日よかったというね
生き方あるんです これで回数券はなくなるんだけど
これには何にもなし あなたにはと
だから落ち込んで妄想するということになっちゃうんです
正しい判断ができなくなって
主観で感情で判断して実行するので
すべて失敗で終わる で
失敗するのは人間の特殊性という言葉もありますけど
トゥーエリスヒューマンとかね
その失敗ではなく 我々の人生全体的に失敗でしょう
結婚する 失敗 離婚する
失敗 子供を育てる 失敗
学校に行って勉強する
失敗 就職する それも失敗
それで仲間とうまくいかない
失敗 なんだ この人生はと
ほんのちょびっと 100円 100
万  200万ぐらいあったら何か証券買ってしまって大失敗
この失敗する理由は あなたの判断が間違っているからなんです
結婚生活を穏やかにいかないならば
この二人の判断に問題あります
なぜならば 判断してから行動する
判断してから喋る 判断してから料理をする
判断してから掃除機をかけるですからね
常に判断があるんです
服にアイロンかける時でも判断が必要なんです
判断間違ったら結果ダメでしょ
食べ過ぎになるのは判断ミスですよ
それで生活習慣病にかかるのは判断ミスなんです
ちっちゃな子供の人見てください
いくら美味しいものを出したっても
あれちょびっと食べて
もういい もういい もういっぱい何も入れませんが断るでしょうね
まあこれ美味しいんだからもうちょっと食べないんです
だからちっちゃい子供はあまり失敗しないんですね
こけたっても それで私たちは妄想していますね
人生の 7割  8割ぐらい
それで妄想って主観で自分勝手で
他の人がやらないもので
だから私がしている妄想は
皆様がやらないんですね
皆様方がしている妄想は
私はやりません だから私の妄想は私だけのものです
そういうことで 自分の主観で妄想して判断するんです
なぜならば 思考妄想似ているでしょ
妄想もなんかおかしく
嫌な理屈っぽく見えるんです
特に精神的に病気の人々と喋ってみてください
えらい理屈なんですね
すべて間違いですけど
だから一般人がみんなやられる
医者さえやられるんですよ
あの連中の妄想に やけに理屈っぽいなんです
医者にもその理屈は成り立ってないっていうことは
ちょっとバレない場合があります
だから私たちは妄想は立派な思考だと勘違いして思考で判断する
しかし 妄想で判断したんです
だからその判断は判断は 100%間違ってます
妄想の判断は一度たりとも正しくない
万が一でも正しくならないので気をつけてください
妄想の結果は まあ例えば
私は誰かのことを嫌いということになる
なって その人のことを妄想する
なんであんな こんなことやるな
あんなことやるなとか
あんなことやってるんだけど
それはおかしいではないかとかね
それは私をバカにしているつもりではないか
私を無視しているつもりではないかと
あれやこれやとか勝手に妄想する
だから私は判断する この人を追い出した方がいいと
正しくないね それで私は偉そうに
やっぱり私はできた人間だから
そういう大胆なことをしてはいけませんと自分に戒める
それも妄想です 結局は
それで では無視しましょうやと決める
そこでその人には嫌な顔を見せる
出て行けとは言わない
嫌な顔をする それ私の判断で行動でしょ
それさえも失敗です その人を殴らないで
追い出さないで 嫌な顔だけでしょ
したのはそれぐらいはいいんじゃない？はないんです
妄想で判断して行う行為
一切完璧に間違いです
完璧に間違っているフレーズはあまり論理的じゃないんだけど
単語ないんです そういうわけでね
いっぱいセミナーやらね
あるでしょう 世の中で
人生 なんだらかんだらね
もう能力を上げるセミナーやらはあるはあるわ
失敗しないためのという本というのは
私が書く本よりはね もう 100倍何倍も売れますよ
理由は役に立たんだからなんです
どんなセミナーに行ったって
どんな明るい 明るく明るい生き方しろ
しようせいとかね この方法でもう半年で億万長者になりましたよとかね
なれるわけないです だったらみんな億万長者だからね
だから妄想ばっかし空回り空回りさせちゃって
そういう妄想セミナーやると代金払っていくんです
すべて失敗でしょ 金無駄でしょ
そういうわけで この人生はまあまあ失敗もあり
成功もありとかね 成功する
成功した人生を送るためにはどうすればいいかとかね
簡単な答え 妄想をやめなさいなんです
もう大胆な知恵がいりませんよ
妄想をやめたらあるのは正しい思考なんです
妄想  妄想は貪瞋痴の感情が引き起こすから
それ自体が悪を犯すことになります
これ一番大変危険なところです
なんで妄想するのかというと
貪瞋痴の感情が落ち着かないんですよ
その汚物が大脳に漏れるんです
だって感情も電気信号で思考も電気
同じものでしょ 全部脳の中
原始脳から大脳まで全てもう神経がもう張り巡らされているんだから
どこかで電気が現れたらダラダラと必要なところに行っちゃいます
だからこの貪瞋痴という汚物で大脳に大脳が感染するんです
それで思考するのは大脳だから
大脳ね もう左ですよ で
そういうことでどうなるのかというと
妄想するとは貪瞋痴を応援すること
貪瞋痴を許可すること
貪瞋痴が悪の根源であると説かれています
それ育てることが人を殴るよりも罪重いんです
酒飲むよりも罪が重いんです
酒飲む人ももうふざけたいんでしょ？貪瞋痴に
何て言いますか の中で気楽にいたいという気持ちで酒飲んだりする
人を殴ったりする場合も
怒りで殴ったりする だからそれ悪行為というんです
だから怒りは何ですかね
怒り自体が真犯人でしょう
殴るという行為じゃないんです
なぜ殴るということは
怒って殴ることもできるし
もう仲良しだから殴ることもできるし
楽しいんだからちょっと殴っちゃえっていうこともできるし
だからというわけで 殴る
その行為自体は大したことないんです
やらせる感情なんですね
これが それでこの妄想することが重罪です
事実 現実 真理に背くために妄想にかける
隠れる これはタイトルに合わない
なぜ妄想悪いというタイトルに合わないんだけど
ただなぜ妄想するのかという
我々ははこの現実から逃避というんですか
逃げたいんです 現実を見たくないんです
それ 脳のプログラムですよ
例えば 私は死にませんという前提で生きている
私は若い元気という前提で生きている
もう 60歳といったって
私はまだまだもう 70歳の人には負けませんよと言うでしょ
あんた方若者には負ける負けませんよと
そういうふうに私たちの脳が自我肯定するために現実を見たくないんです
現実を見たくないんだったらどうしようかと
では妄想しようと で 妄想するんです
だから妄想する人に 何の科学的な事実であろうとも
何一つも発見できません
料理の勉強であろうと妄想ではできません
現実的な思考が必要です
例えば 茹でる品 食べるものにしたっても
食べるものの状況に合わせて茹で時間が様々でしょ
時々一晩水につけておくなくちゃいけないものもあります
硬い豆とかね 大豆とかはそのまま水を入れてガススイッチ入れたっても硬いんですよ
一晩 だからそこ現実的思考でしょ
それで科学者が妄想して科学発展したんでしたね
ある科学者が妄想していると大発見しまったとかありえないでしょう
しっかりした思考で科学事実も発展する
新しい品物を開発できる
そういうことで どうもそこら辺はもう一部の人間がやっているんだからね
我々 我々はそれさらに名前けて
科学者が何か苦労して発見するまで口を開けて待っている
それも結構やられますからね
科学者もね まだまだデータが揃ってないのに
すぐすぐ発表するんです
で みんなそれに乗っちゃって
例えば一人一人にこの遺伝子をプログラム読んでみて
その体にどんな病気になるのか
どこを治すべきのかというと
遺伝子を変えることで病気を作る欠陥のある遺伝子を入れ替えることで治りますよとという理論ばっかしで
まだ実行してないんだけど
一般の方々はまあ近いうち抜群にテーラーメイドした薬飲めるぞとかね
何考えてるんですか ありえないんですけど
で それでそれは妄想なんです
論理的に可能と言ってるだけなんです
そこで仏教の話に戻りましょうか
生きることは苦である
ブッダの真理 違いますと思ってるでしょ？なんてひどい話ですかと
世界のすべての宗教家が大事な命と言ってるのに
尊い命と言ってるのに
かけがえのない命ってなんだこれは
生きることは苦であると
だから私たちは苦ではない
楽しい 楽しいと無理やり心洗脳しているんです
心を無理やり洗脳させるためには妄想しか道がないんです
具体性のない そのうち忘れられますとか
ね それで生きているんです
理性を破壊する 脳が壊れる
これは一番ありがたい結果で
妄想すると理性が破壊するんです
できなくなっちゃうんです
体の脳という臓器も壊れていくんです
自己破壊以外は生産性は皆無です
これは結論の文章です
妄想の結果は自己破壊以外生産性はないんです
次に なぜやめられないかというね
無始なる過去からやっているので
それしかできません 我々はとにかく仏教的に科学的ではなく喋りますけど
命が無始なる過去からずっと変化して変化して流れるんですね
流れですね 命とは 命ってものではなくて
流れで これ流れるんですね
流れる そのものが違うんだけどね
川が流れていたっても
いつでも同じ水を流れるわけじゃないんです
川が流れているが いつでも水が違うんですね
荒川といったら昔からあると
でも過去 いつにある水
流れる水が二度と流れないんです
そのように心 生命は流れるものなんです
だから 生命が無始なる過去から妄想していたんだから
それ以外できないんですよ
論理的な役に立つ思考は先輩から学ぶものですが
人は勉強が嫌いです どうしますかね
だから皆様にも論理的な思考はあるでしょう
役に立つように生きているでしょうに
それは生まれてから学んだものなの
先輩から 生まれつきついていたわけじゃないんです
文字を書くところから
科学 経済学 あれやこれやとか学んだんです
だから論理的な思考は学ぶもので
ついてくるものじゃないんです
生まれるとついてくるのは妄想の能力なんです
自己破壊の能力なんです
だから学べばいいのに
どうも人間が学ぶことを嫌いです
自己満足 自分が正しいという錯覚
義務責任を放棄することができる
時間の流れを気にしないでいられる
そういうわけで妄想するんです
自己満足 自分だけの世界だからね
それから自分正しいという錯覚がしっかりするんです
妄想で よくチェックしてください
妄想するときは 妄想の結果
我は正しいという錯覚が強くなるだけ
それから妄想して義務感
責任逃れするんです それから時間ということは考えちゃうと怖いんですよ
怖いとか心配とかね もうもうものすごいスピーディーにチャクチャク
チャクチャク チャクチャクチャクチャク時間取ってるんだから
だから自分の命をちょっとシンクロナイズしてみてください
今はないんだけど 残念ながらね
昔のチクタクチクタクという時計があったでしょうね
それに自分の気持ちをね
ちょっとシンクロナイズしてみてください
ものの見事に自分の命がチャクチャクと減っていくことを感じるんです
なんとなく怖そうな気がします
じっとしていられないんですよ
さっさと何か大事なことをやっておかないと
お釈迦様がこの火に 頭に火がついた気持ちで生きて修行しなさいと
あれを待つなよと 時間を無駄に使うなよってことなんです
現代的に言えば 服に火がついたように
大した髪の毛がないんだからね
服に火がついたような感じで
もう大事 命を有効に使わなくちゃあかんのです
そこをしないで時間気にしない
妄想すると で 存在欲を許可する
妄想して存在欲を許可します
怒りを許可して 強欲になったり
弱気になったりする で
脳は休めない臓器です
仕事はないから妄想するんです
我々は脳に仕事をあげてないんです
本当につまらないことばっかして
脳にとってはあまりにもちょろいことをやってきているんです
勉強であろうが 仕事をすることであろうか
料理 洗濯であろうか 大した
能力が要りません だから脳がやることがないんですよ
集中して真剣に取りかかる課題ないんです
脳に だから脳がどうします？脳は休めないんだから
やれ ことなかったら妄想します
だから脳は休めない臓器であることも
妄想をやめられない一つの原因です
はい 次に妄想が出す結果
自我を創造する 自分とはその瞬間
その瞬間で変わるものです
時間と環境によって自分は
いわゆる自己セルフというものは変わります
それはこの今読んでいる私はニューロロジーの本
もうかなり立派な本ですけど
まあびっくりするデータいっぱいありまして
まあそちらでも自己セルフというのは成り立たんやと
その瞬間 その瞬間だと
で 仏教で言っていることを言ってますけど
私という気持ちが時間と環境によって変わるものなんです
だから私という変わらないアイデンティティがないんです
で  20年前の写真見て
あ これは私ですと言えないんです
あれ 別人なんです 同級生と酒を飲んでいる自分と
我が子とキャッチボールする自分は同じ存在ではありません
同じだと思うことは妄想なんです
状況に応じて自己が変わるんです
それが真理です 仕方がないんです
それでは自分という存在は成り立たないね
ある 10年前の写真は自分でなければ困ったなと思うでしょ
同級生と酒飲んでる自分と子供とキャッチボールする自分が二つの人間であると
思うと困るでしょう 一般人は
でも二つの人間は同時に存在しません
そこを気をつけてください
時間は一次元なんです
ある時間時間で二つと存在しません
だから酒飲んでる時は別な時間なんです
子供とキャッチボールする時は別な時間なんです
同じ時間でできませんね
だから自分が分離しちゃってね
同じ時間で 3体ぐらいあればなんとかわかりやすいんだけど
そうはないんです いつだって自分とは一体しかないんです
だから違う違う自分なんですね
そうすると無知な人々は心配するんです
あ 困ったと 本当はだから困る必要ないんです
例えば 顔 顔にしわが現れたらなんで困る？ 15 10年前のものは自分だと思ってるんだからでしょ
もう死んじゃったんで
その人は だから困る必要ないんです
存在は成り立たない 無明で存在欲がある生命に処理理解できない事実です
だから生命は無明ですから
それから存在欲があるんだから
この瞬間 瞬間の自分が違うということは
脳に理解できないんです
そういう瞬間を理解する能力は脳にないんです
で 今読んでいる本で まあそれも書いてあった方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったんです
その先生は書いてなかったんですけどね
その人言ってるのは この左脳でデータをまとめてストーリーを作るんだよと
一つに セルフという だからストーリーを作る
左脳がストーリーを作るということは
ストーリーを作らせていられないんだからなんです
だからそこを仏教の言葉もうちょっと上乗せすれば
脳にはその能力がないんです
無常を認める能力がないんです
それで自我を創造していくんです
感情 妄想 思考が助けに来る
そこで脳に 脳に入るデータはすべて無常
自分自分という気持ちがあるんだけど
瞬間瞬間違うんです ただ関連性あるだけなんです
立ってると私の肉体が疲れてきて
それで立った方よりは座った方がいいんじゃないかな
楽々やっていう風に それで立っていた私と今座っている私は全く違うんです
気持ち違うんです 体から出てくるデータが違うんです
でも私は立っていて 座ったと私はとか言うでしょ
皆様 実験してみたってもいいんです
今座っていらっしゃるでしょ
ちょっと立ってみたら
すぐ自分が違うとわかるんです
瞬間で 勇気やったらやってみてください
勇気なかったらもうどうしようもないんです
絶対変わらない自分がいると錯覚を作ってくる
それで感情 妄想 思考 この犯人さん三体が自我を作ってくるんです
変わらない自我という錯覚
自我作れませんよ ないんだから
錯覚が起こるんです 赤ちゃんの時から 80歳で死ぬまで同じ自分だと勘違いして納得する
だから私たちはもうお母ちゃんからずっと私が 80歳までいて
今はそろそろ死ぬんだよという勘違いでいるんです
死後もこの錯覚 死後までいくんです
死後も自分が存在する脳で
存在欲と死という現実との対立がなくなるんです
そこで私たちに存在欲があるんです
あるんだけど 現実は違うんです
決して実らない 叶わない欲なんです
満たせない 満たすこと不可能な欲です
存在欲は そうすると対立が起こるんですね
私は出す 例え話は 例えばお月様がちっちゃくてかわいくて
明るくて美しく見えるでしょ
だから自分の家の置物
飾り物にしましょうと
かっこいいやと あの静かな明かりはとかね
不可能でしょ それでも無知だったら
その人は欲しい欲しいと思うんです
欲しい欲しいと思うたびに苦しく苦しまなくちゃあかんです
私たちもお月様が置物にしたいと思っている人間なんです
どういうことかというと
存在欲 生きていきたいんです
死にたくないんです それは叶わないんです
ありえないんです それで心で対立が起こる
現実と 例えば自分のおじいさんおばあさんが亡くなると
なんでそんなにひどいなんて落ち込むんですかね
あの対立なんです 冷静であ
そうかということでいられないんです
時々友達の誰かが自殺したら
友達たちが悩むこと そこまでと友人のことを心配したならば
ずっと前からもね 親しくすればいいのに
その時は喧嘩したり無視したり
いろいろ自分知ってる人が自殺したら
同じ年の人だったらものすごいショックを受けちゃうんですね
まあ日本でよくあることで
相談も受けたことありますからね
悩んで悩んで 私には何かできたはずですけど
できなかったとかね あれやこれやと過去のことを妄想する
だから その時の悩みもなぜ生まれるのかと
現実と気持ちの対立なんです
それは必ず対立するんです
あり得ないことだから
それで我々はうまいこと自我という錯覚を作るんです
頭がおかしくなるんです
それで自我が死なないと決める
決めて死んでからも 私の魂はもう極楽道で往生されて
金の花の上でずっといるんだぞと思っちゃうんですね
そういう対立がなくなるんです
例えば死んだらアミダ様が迎えに来るんだよと言ったら
対立がなくなるんです
あ そうか 大丈夫かと 執着が不可能な無常たる現象に執着して
限りのない悩み苦しみに陥る
それでどうなるのかと
結果は人間が これで対立がなくなるって言ったってもバカでしょ
完全に非科学的な証拠
ひと欠片もないものを信仰して
結局は苦しみが増えるだけ
無常は無常で見ない限りは
人間には救済はありません
できるだけ早く行きます
で なんか今読んでみると
ちょっと難しい 私は今日は楽チンだと思っていたのに
ちょっと気持ちを楽にして理解してください
邪見しか見解はないと
データ 証拠に基づいた思考は面白くないんです
疲れるんです 皆様のことを言ってるんです
皆様方 真面目に役に立つことをやろうとすると
すぐ疲れるんですよ 勉強になる本を読むと眠くなるでしょ
漫画読むと眠くならないね
かわいそうですよ 人間っていうのは
何か新しい技術を身について
もうちょっと収入がいい仕事をしようかなと思って
欲だけあるんだけど 新しい技術は学びたくない
新しいものには挑戦したくないんですね
だから この役に立つ思考思考
はみんな面白くない 疲れると言っちゃうんです
だからみんな勉強して疲れるんだけど
漫画を読んで疲れませんね
大事な話を聞くと疲れますが
音楽を漫才聞くと疲れませんね
証拠が揃うと考える必要も
結論に達するための苦労もなくなるので
人は刺激を感じない  例えば料理を作らなくちゃいけない
奥さんが出かけたくない
出かけられない 何かの訳があって
それで自分の子供か旦那にこれこれこれ買ってくださいとちょっとメモを書いて出す
それぐらいで全然刺激がないんです
旦那さんがメモを持って行って
スーパーでメモ通りに必要なものを買って戻ってくる
刺激がないんです 本当は刺激があるはずですが
人間そう思ってるんです
そこで旦那さんがスーパーに行って友達に挨拶したら
レジの女の子にちょっとちょっかい出したところで刺激なんですね
だから私たちは日常で大事なことを思考したり行動したりすると
刺激がない つまらない
退屈という変な気持ちになる
だから別に刺激を求めていく
刺激を求める世界 すべて妄想の世界なんです
音楽 映画などなど パチンコ
麻雀 妄想の世界です 妄想には証拠は要りません
だから妄想の場合は証拠は要りません
自分だけの妄想だから
五根に入るデータを熱装して使えば良いのです
だって誰だって五根持ってるんだから
誰にだって同じデータ入ってるんですよ
それで一人一人が自分好きなように熱装する
熱装したデータで妄想する
怪獣 エイリアン 神話 魂
森羅万象の創造 死後の世界
天国 地獄などなど 考えられるのは
それは妄想からです あの
あの オープニング画面に書いた絵もそういうことで
そんなのは考えられるのは妄想できるからなんです
自分の都合にあんなもの気持ちいいでしょ？刺激でしょ
あのドラゴンの絵でしたけどね
だから人間にとっては妄想はやみつきになっているんです
もうやりたい やりたい
だから神話があるわ もうもう空飛ぶ絨毯の話があるわ
もうシンデレラがいるわいるわいるわ
いくらでも 現代人に見たらね
いろんな子供たちに怪獣がいるわ
エイリアンがいるわ 妖怪がいるわ
妄想病にかかっている人には邪見しか見解はありません
それで私たちは妄想して
これはこうだ これはこうだ
これはこうだと思っちゃうんです
私の意見はこういう意見だと言ってるでしょ
でも仏教から見ればこれ邪見です
だから私の意見と思っている意見一つも役に立たない
信頼できない 調べないと妄想の結果でできた結論です
全部 はい これから経典の例えを使ってます
心はマジッショスですというね
で ただ例えを取っただけで
経典は参考にしてないんですね
例えば話はあまりにも現代の科学に合わせちゃったんだからね
ちょっと経典から脱出しちゃったんです
ないものをあるもののように
あるものはないもののように認識させて
心は詐欺をやっています
私たちはいつでもあるものはない
ないものはあるという逆さまで五根のデータは取っているんです
心は自分を騙す 他を騙す
だから私の心は真っ先に私を騙っているんですよ
お前は死ぬわけないでしょうと
お前は完璧な人間だと
お前なんか間違うはずはないんだと
間違うのはみんなやと自分を騙しているんです
私の意見正しいと よくそんなことを思うんだから
だから自分の心 先に自分を騙す
それから世間を騙す 我々は我々の認識は決して信頼できません
認識は信頼できません
この言葉を使ったのは
これは借りた言葉で ニューロジストの先生方の研究から
論文から借りた単語です
思考には信頼性はないんだと
五根から入るデータを瞬間に捏造しています
この捏造という単語を私は今読んでいる本では別ウィービングストーリーと書いてあったんだからね
だからデータは自分でストーリーを組み立てて取っちゃうんです
それが概念になって思考する
妄想すると言って 現実からかけ離れた幻覚の世界を作って抜けられない苦しみ
悩み 苦しみの罠にはめられているんです
だから心が最初からもうマジッショスで
ないものをあるように見せる
あるものはないように見せる
例えば女の人を舞台に上に立ってもらって
手を振ってもらって もうほとんど裸同然みたいな服を着て
で 三回 四回ぐらい回ったりして
みんなに拍手までして
それでなんとか布でずっと被っちゃえばもういないんですね
マジック そういうことでしょう
あるいは何か箱に入れて
箱はノコギリで切る 切ってみたらいない
そこで感覚のいるところ
後ろからどんどんどんどん出てくるんじゃないんでしょう
その人は だからそういう風にこの
マジックやってます 心は
仏教のことはこのネタ
マジッショスのね ネタをバラすことです
そこで妄想して幸せならいいんだけど
これはありえないんです
暗い妄想をしても幸せになりません
病気になりますね では明るいことを考えたら病気になります
どちらでも現実離れだからね
例えば私は失敗するはずがない
この試験は満点で合格できる
明るい思考でしょ それで勘違いして落第
落第するんです 妄想はどちらでも良くないんです
ポジティブであろうか
ネガティブであろうか
それでいいと段落は終わります
でと ９時まででしたっけ？ はい ９
時までです  あと半分がありますけど
（笑）休憩取りますかね
一番大事な後半はものすごいポイント
大事な仏教的なところですけど
では始まります 本当にこのテーマを作った方々が知りたかったのは
妄想がなくなったらどうなるのかということはね
しかし 私たちは妄想がないことを知らないんだから
一応妄想の世界ばっかり説明しました
で 後半では妄想なくなった世界に入ります
で これ 妄想をなくすことはやっぱり極端に難しいんです
不可能ではないんです
脳にその配線がないだけ
現実を見る 作ればいいんです
だからそれなりの実践があるんです
妄想をなくす実践 で 妄想をなくした
なくす状態 お釈迦様がヤタブータンパッセティという言葉で説かれているんですね
ありのままに いわゆる如実に見る
という意味は 捏造をやめましょうなんです
データを如実にそのまま見る
何もしない 思考しない
だから 論理的には最も簡単な方法なんです
何かする必要は何もないんです
それでブッダの提案は思考までやめなさいと
思考が妄想かわからんだから
とりあえず全部やめてみる
妄想だけではなく 思考さえも信頼できません
概念自体は偏見なので
正しく思考することも不可能です
私たちは思考 思考と思っちゃっても
概念で思考すると その概念も捏造したものでしょ
ですから 思考は信頼できないんです
ヴィパッサナー実践は唯一の方法だから
ヴィパッサナー実践するしか方法はないんです
脳に幻覚を作る 自分を肯定する
妄想思考する 自分の都合でストーリーを組み立てる配線のみができているんです
今の脳の配線というのは
幻覚を作る 自分を肯定する
それから妄想 思考する
それからストーリーを作る
誰の左脳の中でもすぐストーリーを作る
面白い科学者の実験ケースがあって説明します
あの このエピレプシーという
この脳に異常があって
止まらなくエピレプシー何でしたっけ？えっ？てんかん
はい ありがとうございます
これも全く不可能で もう何も管理できない
ばっぶり回っちゃうでしてね
それで脳に問題あるんだから
あのあの 分離する手術するんですよ
左と右の間で配線あるんだから
それ切っちゃうんです
まあコーパス callosum
て言いますけど このコーパスカリウムというものを切っちゃうんです
切ったら左の何やってるのか右のわからない
右の何やってるのか左の方がわからない
そこで左脳がストーリーを作るんだよと
そこでその患者さんの右脳にニワトリの骨を見せる
しかし 左脳は知らない
見たことを そこで 左脳に何かスコップをシャバシャバを見せるみたいですね
そこで 何か聞いたみたいですね
もう 右脳に聞いたら この絵を描こうとし
右脳に絵を描けちゃうと
絵を描けませんだから選んでくださいと
あんた見たことと似ているもの
そこで半分隠してるんですね
左に 左は右脳だから体のね
左の目で絵を選んでくださいといったら
この人は鶏の絵を取る
それで 右を開けて絵を取ってくださいと
スコップじゃなくて その人にこの家を見せたんですね
それで家に似ているものを絵の中からこの人はシャベルを取ったんですね
そこで左脳がシャベルを取って
それでその人になんでシャベル取ったのかと聞いたら
今もう鶏見えてるんです
鶏でシャベル なんでこの手でシャベルを取ったんですか？と
ただ この人は だってこいつはうんこを出すんだからね
それは処分しなくちゃあかんですよと
瞬時に何のこともなく言っちゃったみたいですね
鶏のうんこを取り出すためにシャベルを取ったと
だからまるっきり嘘でしょ
だからそこで言いたかったのは
この左脳が瞬時に自分の都合によってストーリーを作るんだと
あっという間に だから私たちは捏造するということにしているんです
そういう実験データは結構ありますけど
脳にはその能力があるんです
幻覚を作る ストーリーを作る能力
簡単な方法ですが 実践はスムーズに進みません
ですから ブッダの実践というのは
世にある一番簡単な方法なんです
掛け算割り算ほど難しくないんです
皆様知ってるでしょ？ただ単に実況中継するだけ
掛け算足し算ほど難しくないんです
たって簡単 しかし脳にそれできないんです
これ実況中継は 思考をやめて歩くことはできないんです
左足上げる 下ろすとやらせてるでしょ
あれは左脳を我々はロックするんです
ストーリー作らないように
左の仕事をあげているんです
だって言語も両方で言語使えますけど
大体左ですからね 言語使ってください
左足上げる 運ぶ 下ろす
右足上げる 運ぶ 下ろす
感じてくださいというのは
データだけ取ってくださいと
軽くなったなと思ったらアウト
足が重くなったなと思ったらストーリー作っちゃうんです
なんだろうね これはと
瞑想間違ってるんじゃない？とか私に聞くんです
すごい面倒くさいんですよ
間違っても だって妄想したんだからね
だからこれもう 2 たす 2 はいくつかと聞くよりも簡単な方法なんですけど
これが人間にとってはすごい難しくなってるんです
理由は 脳にその配線ができていないからです
この瞬間だけで成り立つ自分を観察するんです
だから過去はどうでもいいんです
将来どうでもいい 今の瞬間の自分を見てくださいなんです
あなたは今の瞬間の存在よと
あなたの命は瞬間やと
それ見て それだけ ブッダの膨大な経典で
瞑想法もものすごい資料ありますよ
膨大に ポイントはたった一つです
この一つです はい 妄想をやめた時
真理を発見して解脱に達しているから
妄想をやめた時の状況は説明できません
妄想をやめた人は 妄想をやめた時点で
もう真理を発見するんです
あの苦しみの感情が消えているんで
貪瞋痴が悟りに達しているんです
それはもう我々に経験ないからね
喋ったっても意味がない
喋れない 言葉ない しかし
俗世間の概念を使って
その過程と結果の説明はできます
過程と結果はで説明できます
早く進みます ます 思考妄想で失敗ばかりする人生になりますが
それはなくなります すごいおいしい話じゃないの
だってみんな成功したいでしょ
俺  1万分の1万回失敗して1回成功したって
もうなんだこれはと 妄想をやめてみてください
何やっても成功なんです
常に正解を見えてきます
南無こと人 ああ どうしようかね
これは困っちゃう どれなくなっちゃうんです
あのね こうしなさい すぐ終わり
みんな私たちは 1週間もこの問題で悩んでるんだよと
どういう問題？あ これはこういうことでしょ
すごい言う だからお釈迦様のところにも持ってきた
ある質問っていうのは
もう何百年も人々は考えて考えてクタクタになっている質問なんです
サラッと答える サラッと答える
びっくりする 聞いた人は
正解聞いたんだから これはもう私たちにもできますよ
ですから 他人のことを気にしたり
他を他を真似したり 優柔不断の気持ちでいることはなくなります
またおいしい話でしょ
いつでも人のことを見て
人の真似をして 自分に自信がないんです
何が正しくて何が正確かわからない
だから ちょろっとちらっとやってることを見て
その真似をする それは情けない生き方なんです
何か自分でやったってもいいのか
これでいいのか 大丈夫か
大丈夫か 優柔不断なんです
すべて消えるんです 人格向上
脳の開発 脳の中にデータを熱送する配線が理性的になります
そこで脳の中に変化が起こるんです
ゴキブリ見たら気持ち悪いに決まってる
ヘビは怖いに決まっている
ケーキは美味しいに決まっている
とかね ではなくて 本当に見えるんです
まあ美しく見えるんだけど
このケーキ美味しいかどうか分かりませんと
今日は店に行って 高いお金でチーズケーキあって
たまに私は食べますからね
これはまあいいや 美味しいかどうかわかりませんと
で 買わなかったんですけど
だから私はもしかすると美味しいでしょうね
でもいらんし だから買わないという悩みはなかった
まあわからない それで終わり
食べたくなったら 美味しかろう
まずかろう 買いますよと
買って食べてから美味しいか
そこで判断するんです
これはすごい美味しいやと思っても買わないんです
だから買い物を失敗しても楽しいんです
とにかくこの新しい配線ができる
物事を理性で見える まあふざけて見たければ見られますよ
どれでも 要するに 世間の立場と真理の立場は明確に区別します
何回もあった 私も 12月になってくると
誰か誰にケーキ買ってあげて
なんでケーキ？で あのね
クリスマスだからケーキ食うのは決まりですよと
ただ世間の馬鹿げた話に乗っただけで
別に気持ち的に乗ったわけじゃなくて
私はふざけて遊んでいるだけ
別になんで？なんでクリスマスにケーキ食っちゃうの？とかね
こんなのどうでもいいよ
私には 食いたければ食い
食いたくなかったらやめなさい
それで終わり で ということは
この妄想がやめたからといって
世間と合わなくなったわけじゃないんです
たまにいるんですよ もう瞑想が失敗しちゃって
私はもう実況生きてるんだから
日常生活はできなくなりましたと
これはありえないんです
その人に問題があるんです
瞑想を実践して日常生活ができなくなったということはありえない
もう欲がなくなったんだから
仕事を辞めましたと もともとあんた病気でしたでしょうと聞きたくなるんです
瞑想成功すると 仕事は金が入ってもなくても
やっぱり忙しくてやることがあって面白くないということでやっちゃいますよ
だから雇っている側からお前最近倍仕事をしているんじゃないかなと
それでもニコニコしているのではないかという結果になるんです
それまた甘い話でしょ
それは嘘じゃないんです
やってみてください 超能力の世界じゃないんです
これは脳開発の世界です
で 主観で自分の都合で物事を認識したり
判断したり 行動したりすることがなくなり
好き勝手に行動することはなくなって
正しく認識したりするので
自分だけではなく周りの人々も助かります
今まで私たちやっていることで迷惑
迷惑 なんであんたこんなことやったのかい？と言われっぱなしでしたでしょ
なくなるんです 自分の主観で判断しないんです
客観的に判断するんです
判断して行動する その客観的な判断は自分も助かるし
周りも助かるんです 困っている
わからない どうしよう
心配という心配という気持ちから解放されます
これまた美味しい話じゃないの
すべて美味しい話ばっかしです
次 感情に入ります 思考妄想は貪瞋痴の感情があるから起こるんです
無明だから感情が現れます
それは覚えておいてください
覚えておいた方がいいと
無明 物事を見ていない
誰だって無明 これで如実に見るということで
物事を見ることにする
すると無明がなくなる
無明がなくなると 貪瞋痴もなくなっちゃうんです
如実に見ることに成功したら
感情は成り立たないことになります
感情を司る脳の組織は元気です
しかし 脳は自己破壊ことはしません
役に立つことをこれからやりましょうと
悪感情のエネルギーは他を憐れむエネルギーに変わります
今まで貪瞋痴で生きていたでしょ？妄想して罪ばっかりやっていたでしょ
この妄想もエネルギーですよ
貪瞋痴が それ消しちゃったんだから
そのエネルギーは純粋に憐れむエネルギーになるんです
憐れむっていうのは 人々を助けましょうよと
生命を助けましょうよと
協力しましょうよという気持ちになる
わがままなくなっちゃう
俺が忙しいとか だからいきなり人生が人の役に立つ人格に変わっちゃうんです
あんた本当に役に立ちますよと言われる人間になるんです
またおいしい話です 体も心も落ち着きます
今燃えているんですよ
これなくなってずっと安穏に落ち着くんです
それから安らぎ 脳は休まないから
思考妄想で破壊活動しているんです
脳もIS組織も同じですよ
アルカイダ組織も休みませんよ
あのグループも頑張ってます
しかし やっているのは人殺し
テロ行為 我々の脳もIS組織と同じなんです
人はやることがなくなると退屈で苦しみを感じます
そこで一般人がやることをなくなると退屈
どこか行こう 酒でも飲もうということになっちゃうんです
メール送ろう 友達に電話しようとか
で 妄想世界に入るんです
妄想をやめた人には やるべき
やらなくてはいけないことなどは一切ないんです
あれもやらなくちゃ これもやらなくちゃないんです
これはすっごい落ち着きなんですよ
例えば 試験が終わった時の気持ちです
ずっとあるんです  2 年間も妄想
猛勉強して 鬼のように
苦しくて苦しくて そこで試験に行く
試験が終わったら 終わった瞬間
どんな気持ち？よくわからないですよ
あの気持ちは あの気持ちで一生いられます
日常の現実的な仕事が終わったら
余った時間で退屈を感じないんです
だから瞑想に成功して妄想減った人が普通に仕事をする
料理もする 人を助けたり
いろんなことをやる それで時間が余ってるんですね
余った時間 退屈 退屈はないんです
なんか安穏で安らぎでいるんです
心の中に安らぎの気持ちが現れるので
精神的な安穏な気持ちでいられます
だから仕事があると仕事に集中する
鬼のように これでこれでこれで
終わったらものすごい落ち込んだ気分です
仕事終わったんだから
一杯飲みましょうはないんですよ
ストレス溜まってるんです
実践が進むと 実践さらに進むと
自分の能力が向上するのだと発見します
だって あの 80歳の人のたとえをもう一度思い出してください
70年間妄想して  10年
20年すいません  20年しか生きてないんですよ
アインシュタインなどの人々は証拠に出せませんだけど
まあかなりの思考で生きてきたんだからね
アインシュタインのすごいっていうのは何ですかね？あの人のすごさは
思考したんだからです
だから皆様にアインシュタインになる能力はあるんです
だって 80年生きていたっても 20年しか生きてないんだから
何アインシュタインですかね
だからヴィパッサナーでいくらかヴィパッサナーをうまくいっていると
あら不思議 いろいろ能力があるんです
感情の制御ができているのだと発見します
それで あ 昔みたいに私は感情の奴隷になっていないと見えてくるんです
不安不満が減っていくことに気づきます
なんか不安が消えていく
不安も消えていく 怒りが慈しみに変わります
今まで怒りのプロでしたでしょ
なんとなく慈しみに変わっちゃうんです
それが 別に慈悲の瞑想しなくても慈しみに変わるんです
明るくなります 今まで悩んでいた問題があったならば
その解決方法を見つけています
例えば どんな人間にもたくさん問題あるでしょう
だから宗教世界は 問題はいろいろ分けて
病気治す宗教があって
商売繁盛の宗教があって
学校合格する宗教があってとかね
神様たちはそうやって店やってるんです
いろんな店 八百万の神々がいるんだから
問題はそれでも問題でしょ
毎日生きることは問題でしょ
ヴィパッサナーやってみてください
我々は特別にあなたの悩みは解決して
私は瞑想指導するときでも個人の悩みを聞かない
この人は病気だなとわかったら
個人の悩みを聞く 集中してくれないんだったら
ちょっと聞くんであって
聞かない なぜならば聞く必要ないんです
何であろうとも消えますからね
問題は あとほんの少し
預流果に達したならば
無思瞑想 合格したら預流果になるんです
世にある様々な意見 見解
信仰 生き方などに戸惑うことがなくなります
本物の哲学者になる 何の意見にもとらわれない
どんな意見のも長短知ってます
長と短所が あの人の意見にも一理ある
この人の意見に一理ある
なくなっちゃうんです
すごい自由になるんです
いかなる見解にもとらわれないことになります
10年後に世紀末あると言ったっても
イエス様もうそろそろ来るんです
新宿の方に スピーカーかけて
もう神様がもうそろそろ迎えに来ますよと
罪人はみんな裁きますから
早く神を信仰しなさいと
毎年ですけど あいつは寝ているんですかね
神って野郎が そういうことを聞いたら
私みたいにニコッと笑って
面白い人間がいるなとかね
時々勝手に漫才やるんですね
その人に会って あのね
君 本当に信じてる？これはと聞きたくなるんですよ
一回二回言ったんです
聞いてやろうかなと 聞いたら何かすごい病気で
精神的になんかかわいそうで
このからかう精神がないんです
やっぱりかわいそうで
慈しみが出てきて どうかそういうことをやってでも
なんとか落ち着いてくださいということで帰ったんです
別に怖くて帰ったわけじゃないんです
ブッダの説かれた真理と世間が言う見解の区別ができます
例えば子供がいると楽しいなと喜びの達した人に言ったら
まあ世間はそう思っている
お釈迦様はこれは束縛から生まれる楽しみだから
まあ相当苦労するでしょ
あなたは将来はと両方知ってるんです
でも違いますよ それもないんです
まあそれはそれは楽しいことでしょうねと
俗世間には束縛は楽しい
でも聖者には束縛がない方が楽しいとわかっているんです
信仰する性格が消え 確信が生じます
皆様の心から信仰という脳にあるんです
何かを信仰するという
あれって恐ろしいみたい
私は褒んでいる 面白いフレーズがあったんです
なんか雷の速さ なんとかの速さですぐ信仰作っちゃいますよ
相当信仰を作りまくっちゃうんです
脳って これは消えるんです
信仰が消えるって 何も信じないということになっちゃうでしょ
暗いね そうじゃなくて
確信があるんです 真理知ってるんだから
邪見が一切消えます 今持っている意見はすべて邪見です
それは消えます それからブッダの道は安全な道なんです
脳を開発するんだから
脳科学者でもないのに
医者でもないのに あなた方は危ないんじゃないです
大丈夫です 医者よりも私たちは大丈夫です
煩悩しか知らない人は
思考がなくなったら死んだことと同じではないかと思い
怯えます 思考をやめてください
思考をやめたら死んだことと同じでしょ
あんた何を言うのかと覚える
怯えるんです 全然大丈夫です
これは確実に幸福に達する道です
安全です 脳は成長して正しく活動するだけです
思考する配線は壊れません
思考をやめる修行をしたんだからといって
思考配線は壊れませんよ
創作するの配線壊れません
ストーリー作って今ひどい目に遭ってますけど
ストーリー作る配線は壊れません
私は講演の中でも 例えばにして前もって準備しませんよ
こちらで作るんです 例えばこういうことをしましょうとか
今瞬間で作ってるんです
だからストーリーを作る能力は皆様よりははるかに高いんです
瞬時にストーリーを作るんです
壊れてないんです だからといって
それが本当かといって
そちらに逃げ隠れることはないんです
ただ無駄なねつ造した概念で思考することはやめる
やめただけです 無駄な思考をやめただけです
今まで経験したこともない鋭い思考能力が現れます
預流果に達したら ものすごい鋭い思考能力が生まれます
思考をやめる道で 抜群の思考能力が現れます
それまた正しい思考能力
だから心配することは一切ないんです
思考しないでいることもできます
それだけじゃなくて 何も思考しないで安穏の気持ちだけでいることもできます
はい それで今日のお話は終了になります
そういうことで 頑張って思考妄想をやめることにしてください
それしか幸福の道がないんです
以上です  スマナサーラ先生
ありがとうございました
ちょうど9時ちょっと前なんですけど
お一人かお二人ぐらいでしたら
もし質問がある方いらっしゃいましたら
マイク回しますが いかがでしょうか
スマナサーラ today
今日はどうもありがとうございました
大変勉強になりました
はい あの 私自身 よくこう
頭の中でシミュレーションというか
こう人と話したり 次の日人と接したり
報告したりするというのを頭の中で再現したり
ストーリー作って 次の日それに臨むんですけど
大体そうすると失敗しちゃったり
何も考えずにその場で対応した方がいいような結果が出たりとか
そんなことあるんですけど
やっぱり構えていろいろ考えちゃうとかなんですけど
そういうのっていうのはやっぱり妄想の最たるものなんでしょうか
で そういうのをなくすのにはどうしたらよろしいんでしょうか
まあはっきり言えば妄想なんですけど
やっぱり脳が開発するまで仕方がないといえば仕方がないんです
本当にそういうことなんで
だから我々はストーリー作ってシミュレーションしてやりますよ
それは能力ないからやってること
誰だってね だから この
実際現場では環境違うんですね
いつでも だからこうした方がいいんじゃないんですかね
もし私が妄想して想像している環境だったら
これでいく ちょっと変わったら臨機応変に変えると
臨機応変に変えるということにした方がいくらかうまくになります
それを先に思考妄想を止まる訓練して
脳を開発した方が その場でストーリーが作れます
はい  ありがとうございました
はい  あ えーと 預流果のお話が最後に出てきたので
それについて質問させていただきます
えっと 預流果に達した結果として
あの 今までのその妄想癖というか
妄想の癖が激減というか
一切なくなるということで解釈してよろしいでしょうか
うん まああの いくらか微妙には残る可能性はありますが
これは自我中心的な妄想ではないんですね
私はあれはあれやこれやとかはなくなって
ただ論理的にね なんでトルコでね
問題起こっているのかどうかねとか
なんでアメリカとソ連が一緒になって問題解決しないのかと
程度の思考 我々は関係ないんだから
妄想でそんなこと考えたってもね
そんなようなものを この俺はこうすればもっと良くなるのかっていう
この俺という思考があまりなくなるとは思います
でもある程度で妄想があるとは思います
それから この結構論理的には考えることになります
それでよろしいですか？ あの
そうですね  その自我を中心に妄想がなくなるというのは
その預流果に至った時の三結のうちの有身見が消えることに基づいているということで解釈して
はいはい  ありがとうございました
はい  今日はありがとうございました
最近 六根の瞑想のお話を時々されていると思うんですけれども
あの 六つの感覚器官に六つのデータが触れて
で それを何か合成してしまうという風なお話だと思うんですけれども
この合成してしまう理由っていうのはどういうところにあるのか
ちょっと教えていただけないでしょうか
だから この脳っていうのは
この我々の神経システム
現れる時からもそこを合成するように神経開発するみたいですね
医者によると 仏教もそういうこと
どんな生命もそれをやっちゃいますよと
だから科学者が人間だけですけど
仏教は他の生き物もデータ合成するんだと
例えば野生の猫だったら
ゴキブリを見たらおいしいと思っちゃうでしょうね
我々は気持ち悪いと合成しちゃうんですね
どちらでもないんだけどね
そういうことで 配線が現れる時は
このセルフ自分という
一束にまとめる これ左脳の場所があるんだけど
今本出せないとちょっとありますけどね
ちょっと面倒くさい で
脳のなんとかなんとかセクションで左脳のね
あって そこは合成するようにできているんですね
だから この六根の話の場合は
眼耳鼻舌身意に入るデータはまず捏造するね
例えば花という言葉も捏造ですけど
何か見て花ともう決まってるんですね
それで六番目 思考するときはもう合成から合成なんですね
捏造から捏造なんです
だから瞑想する場合は思考をやめてよと言うんです
見ること 聞くことをやめてよと言わないんです
思考をやめてよと それはもうひどいんです
思考とは妄想になるんですね
だからあの専門的な瞑想を説明する場合は
六根の瞑想というものがあるんです
あるんだけど 実際は念持経の気づき瞑想は誰でもやっているんだから
その場合は五根ですね
六根 六番目はやめる とにかくというやり方でやっちゃうんです
はい  はい ありがとうございます
はい ではすいません 時間になりましたので
以上で終了したいと思います
最後に皆様で回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーチュアジャンツサッブローカウィナッサトーマーテーパーワントラーヨースティーディーガーイコーガーバウトサッブマンガランラッカーンサッブデバタサ
ッブブッダヌーバヴェーナサッブダンマーヌーバヴェーナサッブサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダー スッティマワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサーニッチャンワッターパ
チャノーチャッターローダンマワッダンティーアーユワンノー スカーンバラン
ありがとうございます
サーリーサーリーサー